hi so maybe you are thinking of studying
the brain you love computers and making
crazy programs and then you learned
about the topic of computational
Neuroscience you find it one of the most
fascinating topics ever and after
watching many YouTube videos on the
subject you are convinced that yes this
is the subject you want to study but
then the question comes up is
computational neuroscience worth it and
today I want to dive into this question
with you by discussing the potential
jobs you could get after studying
computational neuroscience and I think
something that you have to keep in mind
is that when you decide on what to study
for your major there are two main
considerations one of course is your
future prospects such as income and job
security and the other one of course is
passion and how much you actually enjoy
studying that subject and I assume if
you clicked on this video you already
have the passion for the subjects
computational Neuroscience down but
you're wondering a lot about job
security so today I want to go over
eight jobs that I personally know
friends of mine that have studied
computational Neuroscience or Fields
related to computational Neuroscience
have gotten and I think if you're still
in University and you're doing your
undergraduate for example or your
Bachelor you are probably thinking in a
very linear Direction at least that's
what I did when I thought about what
kind of jobs I could get so for example
if you studied conversational
Neuroscience you may assume that you for
100 sure have to do something with the
brain once you graduate and this is
something that I've seen is not really
true so most people that leave
University they actually end up in jobs
that are similar but not necessarily
extremely correlated with computational
Neuroscience so I want you to after this
video kind of broaden your mind for the
possible jobs that are out there and
really think about the skills that
you're learning during computational
neuroscience and not necessarily the
subjects that you're studying so the
first job I want to talk about is
working for a neurotech comp company and
neurotechnology is this up and coming
field or emerging industry at the
crossroads between neuroscience and
Technology bringing new applications
processes products services and or
businesses models aimed at delivering
scalable solutions that benefit people
living with neurological diseases
Healthcare professionals researchers and
payers and this is from Biogen and one
of the companies that you may have heard
of is from Elon Musk is called neuralink
and neurolink has this really vague if
we go to the website as a very vague
definition it just wants to find
breakthrough technology for the brain so
what this exactly mean I'm not entirely
sure but it is for certain that Elon
Musk is just putting a lot of money into
your brain research or Neuroscience
because he thinks right that this is a
field that probably some new
breakthroughs will come from and there
are other companies that are following
his footsteps so I also know that
Facebook and Amazon is investing more in
Neuroscience research search and
computational Neuroscience research but
aside from these extremely big companies
there are also a lot of smaller startup
companies so if you look at this list
for example there's this company called
normal and this is a developing brain
computer interfaces that allow people to
Control software and devices using only
their brain activity and do I think
that's already possible no probably not
but in the future this could perhaps be
possible right that for example with a
very precise EG type of system we could
control games or typing and it is
already slightly possible but this is
only true if we implement the device
into the brain such that we can directly
record electrical activity and right now
that's not really article so most of
these companies are using more
extracranial devices and another related
field is this digital health and digital
Health you might have seen already a
little bit if you use these kind of
health tracker devices so you have for
example step counters such as fitbits or
even your Apple Health right but there's
even companies that take this a step
further so they have these implementable
devices that really track all your
physiological responses and I think if
you study computational Neuroscience
this is also a really interesting field
to go into because the data they collect
and the data that we collect is very
similar and I think the kind of models
we make are also very similar so the
next job that I want to talk about is
the most common job that people choose
and that's of course becoming a
professor in computational Neuroscience
you first have to do a PhD and then a
postdoc then you pray that you get
tenured somehow at a certain point and
then you become a professor but I kind
of want to warn you towards this
direction if you're not entirely sure if
you want to do this because amongst phds
I think only three percent get in the
end a professorship and something that I
want to question with this is that this
three percent is not from the top
universities so most people when they
think about that they want to become a
professor they think about that they
want to become a professor at Harvard or
you I'm not a professor at a very small
local University but the chances that
you become a professor at Harvard or
Yale are even more slim than the chances
of you becoming a professor at a small
local University so I think the road
towards professorship is just very hard
and I've known people that are amazing
researchers and they are still not
considered for tenure so I will link to
this article that gives a perspective of
how to become a professor from a
European perspective so another field
that you might consider is biotech
companies and biotech is very similar to
neurotech but more on the pharmaceutical
side as well as the biological side so
usually people that I know with a more
practical application computational
neuroscience perspective go towards that
feels so for example if you know how to
do animal research this could be a very
good fit for you because you could be in
the Forefront of the developing new
covid vaccinations for example so these
kind of companies usually ask for really
practical skills or very well-defined
modeling skills and I think if you have
one of these two this could be a very
good fit for you then another job you
might consider is scientific journalist
so I think scientific journalism or
scientific Outreach is usually not
something people consider when they
start a graduate school for example but
I think it's a field that's really
interesting and really fun if you're
good at writing so some of the skills of
course they ask for is writing and clear
communication you can think of
scientific journalist positions for
papers so for example in nature they ask
for scientific journalists or even a
scientific editor but you can also think
of as becoming a scientific journalist
for a paper like the New York Times or
other these type of related fields and
the way you would then structure how you
would write an article of course depends
on the type of Mag magazine you would
write for and something that I also find
very interesting is that also for books
that are getting published they usually
also want a scientific researcher that
helps with the research for a book so if
you think for example like a book like
this like biased so usually you have the
main author that writes the book but
they also usually have an extra
scientific journalist or a scientific
person that helps with the research for
these kind of books and fact checks all
the statements that are made and you can
also consider a job like that if you
really love reading books or reading
articles another field that's really
related to Neuroscience that almost no
one considers is actually computational
Finance so if you're into dynamical
modeling and dynamical systems that are
used a lot in Neuroscience actually the
same type of models are also used a lot
in finance so for example if we look at
the computational projects that are
listed here from the UFA we see this
project data driven models for risk
management judgments in trading
activities and actually the type of
dynamical systems they used are very
similar to the ones I've used in
computational Neuroscience for
predicting individual neuron responses
or a group of neural responses they
usually use the information from one
time point or a few time points in the
past to predict future events and the
same type of modeling is applied in
computational finance and another really
big upcoming field in computational
Neuroscience is Network causality which
is partly made by Judea Pearl or he
really push this field forward network
causality is also something that's
highly used in computational finance so
that's really trying to predict how the
market responds from one cause and not
necessarily from correlation so this
kind of goes a little bit further than
correlation and I think that's also a
really interesting field to go towards
if you also want to just earn a little
bit more money than other fields that
I've mentioned before another position
that you can really consider is to
become a permanent scientist software
and scientists are usually jobs that are
not really profiled that much on if you
look for jobs within University there
are actually a lot of permanent Sciences
staff at University that we just don't
really hear that much about but a
permanent staff scientists are usually
called research scientists investigators
and or Specialists and staff scientists
can be responsible for managing Labs
such as lab managers or lab directors
facilities or specific equipment and I
now also know a lot of people that are a
staff scientist for the computational
part of things because usually a lot of
professors are not necessarily trained
to do high complex computational
modeling so I know a lot of bigger
universities now have a department or a
small team that helps with managing
these computational tasks and helps with
these type of questions and also for
example if you're very good at
statistics a lot of bigger Labs also
hire staticians to help with the
statistical analysis of certain
particles so I think usually these type
of jobs are not really listed but if you
have a highly developed skill set and
you don't really want to become a
professor but you do want to stay at
University it's good to for example
email a few people that you know at that
University to ask if there's a position
that's available to you that's not
necessarily becoming a professor another
type of position you can really consider
is to become a researcher at an
independent Institute so throughout the
world there are multiple independent
institutes and independent meaning
independent from the government from
universities and or other organizations
and this type of institutes usually have
very broad research interests and you
have a lot of freedom as a scientist to
propose and do new research so one that
I really know in the Netherlands is
tayano and tayano does a lot of research
in all type of stem Fields subjects and
the only thing they require is that you
did a master and or PhD in a stem field
subject so you can even do a if you come
from Neuroscience you can even do
research on Quantum science if you find
that interesting because they have this
kind of philosophy that if you're
trained in these fields that you should
be able to put your knowledge at
different topics as well and that this
type of knowledge transfer is actually
more important for making the field go
forward than having the super specific
background for a super specific topic
and other institutes that I know of are
the Allen Institute for example in
Seattle they're more focused on
Neuroscience or you can think of the NIH
and they're I think in every country
there are usually a few of these
independent research institutes so just
look up in your country or your Capital
Research Institute
and then usually you will find some
positions and or projects that perhaps
interest you and the last type of job
that you can consider is to work for a
startup company so I think if you work
for a startup company the type of skills
you need are way more diverse because
usually insert up companies they don't
have that much money to hire a lot of
people but the thing that I like about
it is that you usually get to learn a
lot more at a startup company that and a
better bigger company because for
example if you are hired at a startup
company as the computational person then
usually they also maybe want you to make
a website at a certain point or do some
kind of Outreach or maybe they will send
you to a conference and I think this
diversity of skills that you need at
startup companies really allow you to
expand your horizon of what is possible
with a different type of degree so I
would definitely advise you to also look
at these type of startup companies if
you're searching for a job after your
computational Neuroscience degree and
these are all the fields and or
positions that I have heard of if you
know another position or someone that
has done something like computational
neuroscience and I haven't listed it
please put it down in the comments below
because I always love to hear what
people did or do after their
computational Neuroscience degree and
otherwise see you next week bye